oh you will never be a groung I'm a jerk
I'm a jackass I'm a jackass
I feel bad I don't feel bad I don't feel
bad at all
I kind of feel bad I feel a little bad
but not that bad our fans in my bosom
the bosom on my butt cheeks or the
safest part could possibly be I don't
even remember I went on a date with Lal
in the last episode
girl finder that's so creepy that's so
creepy
it's like like the I was gonna say it
was like grinder but that would lead to
a lot of things like I don't use
grinders so how would I know about
grinder but apparently I Bret I read a
relative joke that grinder like dad told
that by that British comedian on Oh
this is like it's like GPS you could see
how close the net and the nearest gay
man is away from you Watson I give me
the sex very hard oh yes yes mark I love
it when you make the sex sex yes
everyone wants to know what my favorite
game was uh I think I'd like lean that's
my senpai forever oh my god ease you're
gonna need a bigger cloud than that for
my senpai if you know what I'm talking
about
hey hey wait a minute
oh god no don't be a dope you again I'm
gonna share something here I literally
oh my god oh wow oh wow I'm the worst
you forgive me the internet won't he
just shot rings every Oh huh no no no I
don't want any no no no please your dad
warned me Aaron got birth by rogue and
[ __ ] this baby ass horrifying thing
first of all oh sorry ruse ruse of that
you can go to the wrap party now well
thank you thank you on that I'm just
gonna fap to this for a little bit and
then well then I'm gonna go the wrap
party a fat party yes exactly
flies out of the house oh come on son of
a [ __ ] oh I killed it already wow I'm
great at my job I did it that's arcade
mode for you budget problems that one is
cousin ed holes in it son of a [ __ ]
screw it duck yes yes nuts
soldier ships Oh baby don't
jizz on my puppies please thanks for
watching all of the videos in this
compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
thread thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye